hey youtubers is Charlie this week on
supernatural Crowley got something of an
intervention Dean finally got his hands
on the first blade and Alaina Huffman
wasn't around but she left a very
notable calling card on the baby
seriously I couldn't tell if he was more
upset about that or about the first
blade
but quick heads up next week is Misha
Collins episode mother's little helper
he directed it my schedules back to
normal so I should be able to post that
by Wednesday morning be sure to
subscribe to get that video so this
episode was about half leaving Las Vegas
and about half national treasure so I'm
gonna do my top five moments and then
I'll do my review careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet here we go
number five Crowley's sex Pizza and
human blood bender if you've never seen
leaving Las Vegas it's a movie where
Nicholas Cage decides to slowly drink
himself to death over a weekend in Vegas
and hires Elisabeth Shue a hooker to
hang out with him while he does it
the movie is this really intense drama
but it was all I could think about while
this was going on you know in between
laughing he really did just seem like an
aging Rockstar heroin junkie and number
four Crowley's intervention I love Dean
barking and Crowley's face like he was
gonna yell him sober it also reminded me
of the dog Dean episode I feel like I
missed the addictive aspect of blood in
the previous episodes I always knew he
enjoyed it but I didn't know that human
blood had the same effects as a human
taking intravenous drugs the way Crowley
played it up to it made it seem like
human blood for him was like heroin
laced with acid with some cocaine
sprinkled on top you know just to make
it extra addictive number three
Snooki at the crossroads I will admit I
totally hate Snooki but this was
actually pretty funny
especially the implication first that
she was only famous because she was
getting fringe benefits from working for
Crowley and to that before they left
they exorcise the demon inside of her
kind of teasing that Snooki wouldn't be
famous anymore now that there wasn't a
demon possessing her I am all for the
Winchesters performing a Snooki exorcism
on our televisions you know just make
her go away forever
number two first blade national treasure
this was everything you know up to the
point of deputy Andy from Eureka going
all creepy I love the men of letters
lore and the mad science spell aspect of
this way more interesting than the
Crowley as
key story when he said he had to zoo in
his pocket dimension house I instantly
thought of the island of dr. Moreau and
part of me is wondering now if he was
using spells to try and mess with demon
DNA although if their ethereal beings
maybe they don't have DNA mmm
deep monster thoughts you could have
done an entire episode inside this house
though just think of all the wonderful
relics he's collected it's like Sam and
Dean should combine all the knowledge in
the spells from the men of letters
bunker with all the weapons from
Cuthbert's collection they have
everything they need to fight a war
against rogue angels and Avedon's demons
although technically I guess based on
this episode they kind of applied that
all you really need is Dean with that
blade in his hand and my number one
moment
Dean activates the first blade they've
continued to tease us with this price
that you have to pay in order to wield
the blade based on Dean's reaction to it
I think we can assume that it just puts
you into a killing frenzy where you just
tune out mentally and can't distinguish
friend from foe
meaning Dean could potentially end up
killing Castiel accidentally if he's
around whatever Dean tries to KO a baton
or he could even accidentally try to
kill Sam based on the teaser for the
next episode it seems like their
brotherly tension is reaching a boiling
point so there may be something there
now it's your turn though let me know
what was your favorite moment and do you
think that Dean is accidentally going to
end up killing Castiel or Sam with that
blade and if you didn't catch it there
was a Stargate Atlantis Eureka crossover
going on underneath all this stuff - you
all recognize sheriff Andy of course
from Eureka
he was major Lorne on Stargate Atlantis
and Dean Marshall who played that CSI
investigator was Sergeant Bradley on
Stargate Atlantis and he was dr. Herrera
on Eureka I just love Vancouver shows
this actually happens a lot with
Battlestar Galactica actors too so
overall I just gave the episode a beep
because I really was not digging the
Crowley as a junky storyline and I'm
referring mostly to the resolution that
whole Vegas plot I love the idea that
he's addicted to human blood that's
really dark and interesting but I felt
like we didn't need 50% of this episode
they could have just spent the entire
time in this amazing national treasure
esque house there were just way too many
teasers for magical items we didn't get
to see it would be like Harry Potter
if they never explored Hogwarts just a
criminal misuse of a magical Museum I
did totally love everything to do with
the first blade though especially those
music hues that swell whenever Dean
picked it up I wonder if that plot is
going to mirror the human blood Crowley
plot and Dean will just get addicted to
the emotions that the blade gives them I
feel like they were implying that it
gives the bear equal feelings of
invincibility and murderous rage just
like drugs do
although Crowley's drugs seemed a little
bit more euphoric let me know what you
thought about the episode and did you
think about sheriff Andy whenever you
saw Cuthbert
but either way Alaina Huffman is back
next week as a sexy evil nun I can only
imagine what that's gonna be like I
totally think Abaddon is great but I
love Alaina Huffman and also like I said
now that my schedules slowly getting
back to normal I should be able to get
next week's supernatural up by Wednesday
morning be sure to subscribe to get that
right now you can actually click here to
get my last supernatural video and click
here to learn about my top ten Doctor
Who monsters that I want to see during
series 8 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives